As a fat person
I get a lot of abuse.
From example, from people in cars.
People is just a nice word for men.
It's not to be all like
#allmenaretrash,
it's just that it's never women
shouting from cars.
It's just never "I like your fringe!"
Or, "Where did you get those glasses?
They really suit your face!"
It's like they have this idea that
fat people are so desperate
to get laid
that anytime a van blasting loud
music through open windows passes,
we're just like, "Oh my god...
maybe that’s the one."
Here's a public service announcement
on behalf of all fat people.
We don't wanna (boing) you either.
Most of us actually have some err...
(fog horn noise) at home.
At the moment it seems as if
body positivity is the new thing.
It's all over Instagram.
Thin to maybe chubby
white feminine cis women showing
that actually, if they try real hard,
they can look a bit fat too.
Don't get me wrong, society has
made it very clear that no-one
fat or thin should be happy
with their bodies.
We're all struggling.
But the people who are the most
oppressed in society
like actually fat people, black
people and people of colour,
queer people, trans people, Muslims,
people with disabilities
are not at all represented
in the body positivity movement.
So here is what has happened,
and strap in because this
is excellent information.
In 1967 as a lot of social movements
called for justice,
a "Fat-In" was staged at
Central Park in New York.
500 fat people gathered to eat
ice cream and burn diet books,
which, FYI, I will now be doing every
Sunday in Hyde Park - join me.
NAAFA, the National Association
to Advance Fat Acceptance
was founded in America
in 1969 by Bill Fabrey,
in response to discrimination
against his wife.
#relationshipgoals
The next time someone is rude to you,
if your partner doesn’t start
a social movement...
#leavehim #boybye
In 1973, two people called Judy
Freespirit and Aldebaran wrote:
the Fat Liberation Manifesto
which called for fat people
to have equal rights.
Declared that the diet industry was
the enemy and stated that they were
fully entitled to human respect
and recognition.
There were a lot of points
in the manifesto
and none of them were
love your curves or
#yourbodyisbeautiful.
Because it doesn’t matter
how much I love my curves,
I will still be discriminated
against on a daily basis
and have a harder time buying clothes
anywhere that doesn’t
have flowers on it.
And I will still have men
shout at me from cars.
Fat has been made into body,
to make it more palatable.
And liberation has been
made into positivity,
to remove all accountability
from the perpetrators.
Body positivity is just another way
of asking women to smile.
Thankfully, women love
being asked to smile.
Oh no wait, no wait umm...
women love having autonomy
over their own bodies.
I always get those two confused.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)